[Music]
in this world there are good guys and
there are bad guys and I will not be
bullied into submission you're reading
the man's part Oh God would you like to
start over
yes I would I will not be bullied into
submission sorry to interrupt your wife
is on line two
I'm interested in real parts got 83
dollars in my bank accounts and I don't
know if I can pay my gas bill rude
there's an audition they're looking for
unconventional women whatever them hello
ladies
I'm Sam Sylvia and this is gross sorry
what's glow gorgeous ladies of wrestling
are you hiring actors to play wrestlers
or are we the wrestlers oh yes Christ
[ __ ] actresses okay I want you to
meet the star of glow debby Egan
are you insane why is she here she's the
alpha and you're the Omega so she might
kill you this is the Basten Howard our
producer this is my first Hollywood
party there are drugs in the [ __ ]
robot thank you
wrestling is about pipe you're a sexy
party girl you're an arrow
you mean stereotype yes bingo exactly
you're a big black girl the [ __ ] you say
lady wrestling I get it women can do
anything then too bla bla bla
[Music]
how about look I got chills yeah you
would we're empowered where the hello
you want the show to happen this is the
only place I get to do what I want to do
people respect me here we got to shoot
this thing like five weeks this could
either feel dinky or it can feel epic so
let's give them one look to it
storytelling storytelling this is about
justice this is about holding on to
what's ours
the gorgeous lady
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]